So when we're talking about trust for AI we
hear about these five pillars, right. Awareness,
robustness, privacy, explainability, and
transparency. So, what is all of this?
You're right Aishwarya. There are you know,
at this point in time we usually talk about
five different pillars, but keep in mind that
this is a fast evolving space. This field is
changing rapidly. But at this point we
usually talk about fairness, robustness,
privacy, explainability, and transparency. Let's
maybe talk about each of them quickly. Fairness
is probably obvious it is to make sure that the
models are not behaving in a biased way. Now it
may actually start, the challenges may start way
before a model is built. It might be understanding
if the data itself is biased. If it is how do you
deal with that? When you build a model how do you
make sure that the model is not systematically
giving an advantage or a disadvantage to a
certain group. And the definition of the
group varies by industry, by use case,
it could be based on sensitive attributes like
age and gender and ethnicity, but may not be
limited to any of those. You want to make sure
that the system is not consistently favoring one
over the other in an unfair way. Robustness, you
want to make sure that your models behave well
in exceptional conditions. How do you make sure
that the model performance is good over time?
What is happening with the effective data drift?
Or for example, in the context of the of the
pandemic, we know that customer behavior has
changed you know customer patterns have changed,
customer touch points have changed. Is your
model still behaving as expected, or if it is not
can you at least have an understanding
of how the model behavior is changing,
how data is drifting, how accuracy is drifting,
etc. Privacy, can you make sure that the model,
the data, the model that is built off of
that model, the insights from that model,
they are all that the the model builder
owns and retains control of those insights.
And how do you do this not just as in terms
of consumption of the output of the model,
but across the life cycle. How do you make
sure that data protection rules are in place
through the model building testing validation
and monitoring stages. Explainability is probably
pretty obvious. How can you explain the behavior
of a model. Why was someone approved for a loan,
why was someone rejected. When somebody applied
for a job and that person was selected but someone
with very similar qualifications applied that
person was rejected, can you explain the behavior
to the end user or to a decision maker.
Transparency, you want to be able to inspect
everything about a model. Can you understand
all the facts surrounding the model. Who
built it, what data is being used, what
algorithms, what packages are being used,
who approved it, who validated it. All of these
aspects of the model, facts about the model,
should be easily available. Just like you know,
you have you buy a food product and there is a,
there's a label on it, you know, it has the
nutritional facts, when was it manufactured,
where was it manufactured, all of that. Just
like that for a model, you should be able to
get the facts of that model very quickly. So
these I would say are sort of the fundamental
pillars of Trustworthy AI. The challenge is
making sure these can be done in a systematic
way regardless of what tools are used to build
the models and where the models are deployed.
So John, in the recent past, we have seen that
as AI systems were new to a lot of organizations,
organizations have very recently adopted such
large-scale AI applications or systems in
their workflow. And that's where we started
seeing these side effects of AI, right. And
that's where we pinpointed that, hey, like these
were some of the aspects which we need to target
to make sure that AI doesn't have an ill effect on
the community, or doesn't have an ill effect on it
on an entire perspective. So when we see that
organizations are facing such challenges,
when they are seeing such like roadblocks
with respect to building trust for the AI,
what is the recommended methodology on making sure
that building such AI systems, or like building
such trusted AI systems is easily done throughout
different business units of the organization and
doesn't surely, you know, it doesn't really
streamline to just one particular department
or team. How can we make it a big thing and how
can an entire organization productionalize this
streamlined work? So Aishwarya, you know, you're
talking about expanding this across our company,
sort of setting up this governance framework and
that was one of the patterns we talked about. Many
companies may not start there, but they may start
with one of the other patterns we talked about,
which is let's start with assessment or building
out a new use case, a new application that follows
Trustworthy AI principles, but yeah some companies
may want to look at a top-down approach and
and set up the governance framework taking
into account that there are multiple streams of
data science and AI activities going
on concurrently. But in all of these,
you know, regardless of which approach you take,
I think three elements need to come together.
And I would say these these are
these three elements are technology,
people, and process. Technology is probably
obvious, we need to have guardrails across
each of the stages of the life cycle.
When you're working with data, how do you
check for bias in the data, how do you correct
that. That's a guardrail at the data exploration
time. When you're building the model you
need a guardrail in place for model building
for checking the robustness of the model, for
providing an explanation in development time.
You need a guardrail which will allow you to go
into valid, through validation into deployment,
and you need an outermost guard where
you think of it as a one-time guardrail
which can continue to do monitoring of your model
and look at how it is behaving against thresholds,
whether the thresholds are being breached, etc.
Now, so technology provides these guardrails
for all of the different five pillars that we
talk about. Now technology in itself is not
sufficient that's why I was mentioning people and
process. People because you need a set of skills
to come together. It is not just data science
skills. The MLOps paradigm requires you to have
the operational skills come together with data
science skills. You might have risk and compliance
expertise coming into the picture. You might have
business analysts and business stakeholders coming
into the picture, and so on. So the right level
of expertise, personas who are collaborating to
achieve this common goal is important. And then
finally, process. In a process, that term process,
you know, people may not always like that, but
the reality is you need a set of best practices
for each stage of the life cycle. Whether it
is coping and building, or it is validation
or deployment or monitoring over time, you need
a set of best practices. So technology, people,
best practices coming together make it possible
to loot Trustworthy AI at scale and operationalize
it. Great, thank you so much John, like
it was very insightful for me because to
understand kind of the AI systems we build, from
understanding it from a data science perspective,
to how it can be productionized and run
successfully in these large organizations. It is
very important that organizations are responsible
to the people who are using it, right. So it was,
it was really insightful that we got to learn so
many different things from you. In the meanwhile,
I feel like there's a lot of other resources
which is available for us to dig deeper and
learn about fairness, robustness, transparency,
privacy, and explainability. So everyone who's
watching this you can find the right resources
in the description below, and soon we'll be
posting more series of videos talking deeper
into each of these pillars. Thank you so much.